bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
greetings up peace to everybody all over
the globe you're tuning in to the D show
and we have a special episode we know
that the Quran is a living miracle and
we have a young girl Mariam many of you
ever saw her we posted some of her
videos on our Facebook page and many
people during the month of Ramadan she
was giving us the Muslim the eight year
old little girl was given the Muslims
advice that's right so we're gonna be
talking to her she's gonna recite from
the Quran all that more on this week's
show we'll be right back I said my
alaikum I'm I am on the game show
I'll be right back
this is the peace be with you assalamu
alaikum Maryam how are you well thank
you for being with us on today's show
you're welcome you're very busy nowadays
you seen you're making a lot of videos
talking about Islam giving the Muslims
giving people advice out there is that
right mm-hm and you're gonna also be
reciting some Quran for us today and
giving us some advice so how old are you
again I'm I'll close up I didn't want to
get that wrong eight years old and you
memorize how many Jews of the crowd I
memorized twenty-one just from the Quran
21 just masha'Allah so we know that
every messenger that came just for our
audience some who are tuning in who are
not Muslim and they know that every
messenger now came with a miracle to
show the people today the last and final
messenger probe Muhammad has the he
brought the Quran which was compiled
over 23 years and it's a living miracle
and you've memorized 21 parts of this
Quran you go your is your goal to
memorize the whole Quran and sha Allah
so tell us now at what age did you start
memorizing the Quran
I started memorizing that boy and when I
was 2 years old as it was it was it
difficult it was it fun it was easy iOS
Bank so it was both and who helped you
my mother helped me memorize your mother
helps you so we also see now that on
some of these videos you're giving kids
advice what kind of advice do you like
to give to the kids I like to tell them
to recite and memorize the Quran and to
avoid listening to music and now why why
should they avoid listening to music
because it's not good for them and it
will block them from realizing
so no Britney Spears no rap music 50
Cent's none of that right
okay just Quran okay so you've learned a
lot about Islam now a lot of times we
mentioned a lot of the different
prophets and most people living in
America they know about Jesus do you
know Jesus
yes do you love Jesus yes who was Jesus
this is the prophet of Allah now do
Muslims worship Jesus no okay who do we
worship alas of ayodhya and who is alone
alas of Ahana today is our God
that's the creator of everybody yes now
you know the five pillars of Islam can
you name those yes after worship prayer
oh how does the rest'll zakat [ __ ] and
so there you go believe in a day
judgment tell me more what you know keep
going
um you have to believe in the Angels yes
yes they do hat Hajj
okay and you have to believe in the
prophets yes beautiful tell us now
you're also in what grade are you in I'm
in third grade third grade and what is
your goal what are your goals now in
life I want to be an Islamic scholar to
get the message of Islam and I want to
be a software engineer like
flies it in this life masha'Allah so
tell us now you were also the Koran
champion at ik now is this right yes
tell us how was this did you enjoy
yourself there was there a lot of other
kids who were competing and how was it
oh it was good and okay so what else can
I ask you I want to ask you before you
give us now you were gonna recite the
Quran and you're also going to you you
we've seen some videos of you making
draws right what's your favorite do op
and I know I do I knew it
okay so will you when we come back
you're gonna tell us what you're gonna
do when we come back what are you gonna
recite I'm gonna be Anna and explain
about it okay that's that's the promise
right because people are excited now we
don't want them to leave and when we
come back you're gonna recite that for
us inshallah okay you've heard it here
from Maryam when we come back you know
my daughter's name idiom also she's six
she's got medium you have she's got just
um uh she's on her second just I'm the
love she's six just turned six but she's
got a lot of catching up to do now so
you guys being a good competition tell
her tell her medium you got it study
hard now tell her tell her man you gotta
study hard you have you have to catch up
to me you hear that Mary yeah okay we'll
be right back with Marian here on the
Dean's show please subscribe to the D
show follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and with where we're
here with our extended family and New
Jersey can we hear everybody so be it
alright hamdullah
so there's a special treat we have met
him here and most of you know her from a
lot of her YouTube videos so now you're
gonna honor us with the Quran you ready
bismillah go ahead
and today
yes Anna Anna
yeah
ha ha
and your hey I'm out now I will explain
a couple of verses from what I just
recited during the time of prophet
muhammad sallallahu alayhi wa sallam the
disbelievers asked him how almighty God
be able to reconstruct our bones when we
die our bones will be disintegrated then
how will Almighty God be able to put
together our bones Allah subhana Allah
replied in surah al qiyamah verse 3 & 4
does man think we shall not assemble his
bones yes we are able to put together in
perfect order the tips of his fingers
what does it really mean or allah
subhana allah says he will not only
reconstruct the bones but also he will
reconstruct the tips of the fingers why
Allah subhana Allah mentioned such a
minor part of our body instead of other
complex organs it is amazing to see that
scientists discovered fingerprints for
identification
nineteenth century two persons having
exactly the same fingerprint is not
possible even in billions Subhan Allah
Allah send this information to our
beloved Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alayhi wasallam 1400 years ago surely
Allah is able to do all things
may Allah subhana Allah give us the
ability to read and understand the
corner and so bahar know why you will be
hungry
so by Hanukkah Oahu Maui behind a shadow
Allah Allah Allah and also Fuuka wa
atubu ilayh the dark allahu khairan wa
salam alaikum
masha'Allah masha'Allah very beautiful
very good job is there anything before
we go you'd like to tell your parents I
say your your mother your father's here
but your mom's not is she here she's not
here
you want to say you saw him leaking to
your mom she's watching you love her say
I love you mommy
all right and there you have it this is
the Quran the verbatim word of God Allah
young kids at age eight are inspiring
and many have memorized it and she and
sha Allah soon will have it memorized
inshallah yes
hum did it laughs please subscribe to
the Biggio follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below